how to get in a state of flow it's a
question I got from one of my readers
Donald Donald no chew or chew Donald
anyway it's a great question I wrote an
email and created a video on flow and
the importance of it and how crucial it
is for your business when you recognize
you're in a state of flow and that's
when things are going right you know it
feels right the project you're working
on you have to keep going with it it's
so important because this is where the
genius is gonna come from and when you
try to force something it doesn't work I
don't know if there's a way to
deliberately create flow because if you
try to force flow it's not going to
happen right but what you can do is give
yourself the conditions to create
something amazing being in the state of
flow is like create an art or it's like
being very creative you know if you come
down on people and say okay we're gonna
have a brainstorming session everybody
meet here we're gonna be creative right
now you don't get great ideas because
you can't force creativity you can't
force flow in my opinion but you can
give yourself to conditions that will
best lead to flow here's what I find
super helpful I give myself freedom
again when you try to force something
okay now I want to get into the state of
flow it's probably not gonna happen and
when you're stressed out when you're
under pressure when you have deadlines
coming up then it's also really hard to
get into flow because you've got
something crunching down on you I try to
build a business that is not reactionary
I tried to build a no-pressure company
so that myself and the people on my team
are free to explore are not crunched
down just putting out fires all the time
that's most companies right you're just
putting out one fire that's telling you
go in another fire now and you never
spend any time actually growing your
business so you want to try to reduce
those numbers of fires free up your time
allow you to focus on bigger picture
stuff
when you freed up your schedule you
freed up your time you freed up space in
your mind it allows your creativity to
enter it allows you to get into the
state of flow and when you get there you
have to run with it if I'm in flow if
I'm really feeling something if I am in
the zone on something I'm working on
I push everything else that I'm doing
I'll cancel meetings I'll push
appointments I'll push deadlines on
things because I need to finish what I'm
doing because if I don't finish it now
it's gonna take me ten times as long on
another day and it won't be as good if I
ride with this genius right now what I'm
gonna end up with is amazing and as
entrepreneurs we don't get into flow
that often right it's not like every day
you're in flow if you're writing a week
of great flow you are lucky a lot of
times we are stuck forcing ourselves to
do something and that's important for a
business but the real growth is going to
come when you are in that state of flow
it starts by opening up your schedule so
leave time every day for what I call CEO
time this is where there's nothing
assigned you're gonna work on something
to grow your business but you don't have
a fixed project or something that you
have to get done take breaks off I like
to break my day into 90 minute chunks
and then take 15-minute breaks in
between and I'll go outside go for a
walk whatever it is just clear my head
I'm taking those breaks refreshes my
mind do something active physical I love
salsa dancing I do that 20 hours a week
and I get most of my best ideas most of
my creative ideas when I'm not in the
office sitting down in front of my
computer
maybe I'm the strange one but if you're
like me then you've got to get out you
know you get your ideas we need in a
shower you get your ideas when you're
you're going for a walk when you're
doing some kind of physical activity and
went on vacation when you're relaxing
how many times did you go away on a
vacation and come back with a million
different ways to grow your business
then that's a big idea to help you take
off
because you were relaxed and not under
huge amounts of pressure so again I
don't think you can force flow you can't
say flow right now bring it we're gonna
do something but you can create the
conditions that will bring it out to the
best of your abilities and it starts
with having as open as schedule as
possible and having a no crisis business
belief if you guys like this video
please leave a thumbs up below thank you
for the great question and if you have a
question for your company leave a
comment I'll do a video response I love
seeing you guys I love answering your
questions that makes my Wednesday every
week when I sit down here and I'm
recording these videos I love hearing
from you please leave something below
thank you so much and I'll see you soon